stocke chose you he made you an Avenger
[Applause]
hey everybody it's Charlie's surprise
surprise apparently there's going to be
a spider-man far from home extended cut
re-releasing in theaters in a couple
weeks so I'll break the news down and
talk about the deleted scenes that
they're adding back in because we also
found out what all the deleted scenes
and blu-ray bonus features are going to
be and it's way more stuff than they put
on the Avengers end game blu-ray which i
think is kind of funny because endgame
was a much bigger film you would think
that they would make a much bigger
blu-ray with way more bonus features but
apparently Sony is rolling hard on
spider-man far from home so if you're
brand new to the channel we're doing a
giveaway for the spider-man far from
home blu-ray all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave your
best spider-man 3 theory on the video
what happened earlier today is that on
reddit a theater manager of a chain
posted an email he says he got recently
about Sony re-releasing spider-man far
from home and extended cut in theaters
with a bunch of extra footage added in
the exact same way Marvel re-released
Avengers endgame in theaters with a new
post-credit scene or a couple new post
credits scenes and some extra footage
but looking at what the email this
person posted says the Spider Man far
from home free release and new footage
sounds way different and way bigger than
what they did for Avengers end game so
for all the people that are shaking
their fists and were dissatisfied with
what the extended cut of Avengers
endgame was it sounds like the Sony
version of this will be better I did a
couple of separate videos for those
Avengers and game new post-credit scenes
so I'll link them at the end of this
there was the Hulk post-credit scene
that was basically a deleted scene of
Professor Hulk that they had gotten rid
of before they finished visual effects
explaining more about him becoming
professor Hulk after the five-year time
jump
there was the Stan Lee cameo scene and
then there was the spider-man far from
home scene here's the actual email that
the guy posted so you see immediately
why this seems a little bit different
than what they did for Avengers endgame
so he says I'm the manager of a theater
we just got an email about this and it
describes as follows on August 30th for
Labor Day weekend Sony Pictures
Entertainment will be re issuing a
director's cut of spider-man far from
home into theaters across the
country.this director's cut will feature
unseen footage added back into the film
for an all-new spider-man experience
there will be a major marketing campaign
behind this new cut so we are asking for
everyone's support in playing the
picture in both the regular and PLF
screens just the different types of
actual movie screens inside theaters the
theater manager works inside the United
States so he's saying that he doesn't
know if this is gonna be happening just
in the United States or if it's gonna be
worldwide but I would assume if they're
gonna copy what Marvel did with the
Avengers and Game Reaper lease they
would do it worldwide as well there's a
lot of things to unpack in that email 5
why would Sony re-release the director's
cut of spider-man in theaters to begin
with it already made over a billion
dollars in theaters it's the highest
earning spider-man film of all time the
email says Labor Day weekend that's the
weekend after the Marvel d23 panel this
is all probably part of the reason why
they haven't talked about spider-man 3
yet just because they don't want to
steal thunder from a potential rerelease
with extra box-office money from far
from home when they're not completely
done with that film Sony's getting ready
to shoot venom 2 in the next couple of
months with Andy Serkis
and Quentin Tarantino's DP they actually
just stole him off of Quentin
Tarantino's last film but get this that
same week they're also releasing
spider-man far from home on digital so
there's gonna be a home video release
and this apparent re-release in theaters
with all the extended footage the
physical blu-ray won't come out till
September though but I think overall
Sony just hasn't had a ton of box office
smashes during 2019 and because
spider-man is their crown jewel it just
seems like they're taking a page from
Marvel and just capitalizing on all the
extra bump that they would get from a
rerelease but there's no record that
they're trying to beat it's already the
highest earning spider-man film of all
time it's not like avengers endgame
where they were trying to inch out
avatars box office record to become the
highest earning film of all time
worldwide for on top of that the fact
they're calling this a director's cut is
kind of weird because extra footage is
always awesome I always love seeing all
the extra stuff that they cut out of
these films they shoot like three to
four hours of footage and then by the
time they're finished editing it is down
to two and a half hours avengers endgame
is just like a rare exception because it
went a little over three hours you're
not gonna see a whole lot of comic book
movies go that long we
out doing like some special director's
cut John Watts the director of
spider-man far from home is really cool
he already told us what a lot of those
deleted scenes are and there was a ton
of stuff they had to cut for time not
because Sony forced him to cut it just
because they actually needed to get it
down to about two and a half hours but
the big thing about directors cuts in
Marvel movies is the reason why you
haven't seen them is because Kevin Feige
has made a big deal about saying that
the theatrical cut is the director's cut
once the director finishes his edit of a
film Marvel has a history of trying to
not mess with them one of the few
exceptions is Joss Whedon famously
complaining about the minor hostage
situation he got into over his cut of
Avengers age of Ultron you probably
heard about this is actually fantastic
to hear about a little bit of drama
behind the making of this movie Marvel
told him that they would cut all of his
Hawkeye farm scenes with them being this
dysfunctional family if Whedon didn't
leave in although really weird cave
scenes with Thor because those were the
scenes setting up Avengers infinity war
that was during the era when they were
still using each movie to set up the
next movie in a much more obvious way
they don't do that quite as much now
they kind of let each film do its own
thing
so when this theater owners email says
spider-man far from home director's cut
someone may just be miss speaking and
it's just them letting John watts add in
a lot of the good stuff that they had to
cut for time 3 probably the most
important information we need which
theaters are actually going to have this
extended cut the theater manager posting
here doesn't even say which theater
chain he manages maybe for fear of
getting fired that he leaked this
suppose an email he does say that
there's gonna be some kind of major
marketing push before they do it so
hopefully that's when they'll release
the instructions about where we can go
watch it but they said the same thing
about Avengers endgame and how many of
you saw a bunch of very detailed
instructions that Marvel was posting
about where to go see this it was more
like a couple Marvel Twitter accounts
posting a few pictures in that was it
they mostly relied on bloggers youtubers
like me traditional news outlets to post
all the details for how to go see the
extended cut of Avengers endgame so once
we do get more details about this I will
post an update video but it's not
supposed to happen for a couple weeks so
we still have a little while to even
more
important what are the actual new scenes
going to be we already know about a ton
of the deleted scenes I even did a
spider-man bar from home deleted scenes
video a little while ago there was a
whole section of the movie at the
beginning that was a solid ten minutes
long they had to cut out called Peters
list remember the short film by Peter
Parker at the beginning of spider-man
homecoming and it was sort of him taking
cellphone footage making this short film
about his special trip during Captain
America Civil War they did the exact
same thing at the beginning of
spider-man far from home but it was him
just going through a checklist of things
that he had to do before he could go on
his class trip getting his passport
renewed taking down the Manfredi mob in
the iron spider suit going to mr. Del
Mar's new bodega to buy supplies and
sell his Star Wars toys to get some
spending cash there were a ton of
deleted scenes in that bodega in number
one speaking of which here's the full
list of bonus features and deleted
scenes that are gonna be on the blu-ray
in a couple weeks when they release it
I'll do videos for all this stuff too
when they actually post them just like I
did for Avengers endgame there's a 30
minute special featurette called
worldwide webslinger that's like a whole
other short film in and of itself that's
crazy there's the short film of Peters
to-do list
there's deleted scenes of Betty's blips
that's probably the funny montage at the
beginning what they're doing the news
broadcasts explaining how everybody came
back after the blip there's bus rest
stop with class that's probably just
more of the funny scene of him getting
the new stealth suit and having to take
his clothes off and getting caught by
Brad Beck's green juice is probably just
a funny scene with Mysterio after they
reveal the secret of his character and
he's acting like real Quentin Beck Peter
and MJ on plane and Macy's glasses is
probably from the very end when they're
on the plane on the way back remember
Peter wanted to sit next to her so that
they could watch films and they would
get close to each other they finally did
that on the flight back in May seeing
glasses as pie just them addressing
what's gonna happen with the special
Edith glasses going forward there's a
special featurette for a short film that
Flash Thompson shot on his phone during
the movie remember when he says I'm
gonna get so many followers from this
and he starts taking footage of all the
big action scenes that they get involved
in traditional gag reel and outtakes no
big surprise there there's a whole bunch
of separate featurettes there's teachers
travel to
to jump off stepping up suit up probably
about the new suits now you see me far
far from home it takes too Furion Hill
the Ginter Riva effect Thank You mrs.
Parker
stealthy Easter eggs the brothers trust
that's actually the charity that Tom
Hahn does he does it for all the movies
he's in there's a hydro-man part one in
part two previz with them just talking
about how they made the elementals
there's one for molten man there's one
for the final battle when all the
elemental monsters seemingly formed
together obviously it's an illusion that
Mysterio created there's one for the end
credits scene with him swinging through
New York City first time we've actually
seen him do that since the Andrew
Garfield films then just an extra sizzle
reel so what'll happen is is I'll be
doing giveaways for the blu-ray when we
get closer but it's not coming out for a
couple weeks and when we get more
details about what's going on with this
extended director's cut of spider-man
far from home I'll do some update videos
about that too but congratulations to
the giveaway winner for my last big
video Glenn Watson please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details
everybody click here for my breakdown of
the Avengers what if Comic Con trailer
footage and click here for the boys
season 2 trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you